[Musique]
la 58ème édition du Salon International
de l'Agriculture ouvrira ses portes le
25 février prochain Porte de Versailles
à Paris voir plus grand c'est ce que
souhaite le département avec un stand de
800 mètres carrés pour le village
réunion 32 exposants et un budget de
600000 € pour valoriser l'excellence de
la production réunionnaise
c'est l'occasion de montrer ce qu'il y a
de meilleur à la Réunion matière de
production agricole nous savons que le
monde agricole le monde économique
traverse les périodes difficiles mais en
même temps nous avons aussi des
producteurs femmes et hommes qui est au
quotidien travaille la terre produit et
nous propose des produits de qualité et
ces produits là sont très demandés ici à
la Réunion comme en métropole les mêmes
sur le plan international donc très
belle piscine pour nous je souhaite
pleine réussites à tous nos partenaires
exposants à tous les agriculteurs qui
participent à ce salon international
nouveau dès cette année la marque 100%
la Réunion lancée par la collectivité le
gage d'un produit 100% local et de
qualité il faut plus jamais montrer
notre savoir-faire montrer la qualité
des produits de la Réunion pour faire en
sorte que nous puissions sortir notre
agriculture de cette base difficile que
nous connaissons donc il faut
véritablement se donner et montrer qu'à
la réunion nous avons des produits de
qualité des produits sains et des
produits sans qu'on sent la Réunion
c'est aussi ce qui fait notre force et
nous savons que le Grand Paris sera en
rendez-vous que le stand outre-mer sera
fréquenté et les 800 mètres carrés que
le Conseil départemental met à
disposition de nos 32 exposants est une
chance la Réunion est une chance pour le
Salon International de l'Agriculture la
Réunion est une chance pour la France
à quelques jours de l'ouverture du salon
les exposants sont à la fois impatients
et submergés
ici parce que avec l'ambiance avec le
top départ qui est lancé et après c'est
vrai que dans nos ateliers ben ça se
bouscule c'est pendant 9 jours de salon
on fait quasiment un mois de chiffre
d'affaires ici à la Réunion donc ça
automatiquement ça vient ça vient bouger
un petit peu la production mais en même
temps c'est ça tient de l'évolution et
puis on a hâte on a hâte d'être sur
place alors comment on se prépare c'est
beaucoup de travail c'est surtout de la
production essayer d'élaborer aussi des
stratégies pour être vraiment au
meilleur de notre forme au salon pour
pouvoir aussi prévoir de l'export et de
la vente ça va être essentiellement ça
donc on est à la fois excité et puis à
la fois déborder
le village réunion proposera une vitrine
riche en roux et en couleur pour séduire
les quelques 650 000 visiteurs qui font
les déplacements à Salon International
de l'Agriculture chaque année
[Musique]